joining me this week for the panel are
the president of the American atheist
David Silverman and comedian and actor
Paul Provenza both are godless heathens
so I'm looking forward to sitting down
with you two godless people how did you
get here with your godless lives how did
you how did you do it how did you get
here today we did it without God's you
did it without God not here you got in a
car and everything without God's not
amazing and by the way everybody's
godless there there are no gods so
everybody's godless I'm just aware of it
so you're just laying it out right right
start there are no guarantees Cullis
every single person everyone is godless
do you have an opening that can possibly
Mike I I really just I'm like the guy
that follows the King around with the
buck you say the Jesus of the you're
saying no he's a lot older than thirty
three shoulder all right so there's
there's a lot of stuff I want to talk to
you guys about we've done a bunch of
atheist stuff here and I've had a lot of
well-known atheists but I always feel
like there's more to unpack when it
comes to atheism it's sort of endless so
let's start just simply and I'll go to
you first on this one just give me your
what what your definition of atheism is
because I always find just even a couple
changes of words make it very different
to different people that's that's a
really good point
and I are under the impression usually
with negative connotations that you know
Oh atheists think they know there's no
God but really I really subscribe to the
the parsing of that which is that that's
not the case what it is is that is
unreasonable for me to believe that
there is a God that reason tells me that
there is no God it's kind of like UFOs
if a UFO came and landed in my you know
in my backyard I'd be the I be the first
one to say you're not gonna believe it
there's aliens they just came in from
outer space if there were any evidence
if there were anything that would allow
my reason to believe that there were a
higher power
then I would certainly consider it but
there is no reason right okay so I like
that definition and that's basically
what I laid out that this is basically a
lack of belief until someone was to
present evidence otherwise and you would
really write well now when atheists say
there's no God that's really just a it's
just a drive by it's just the shorthand
there is no God not saying that they
have proof that there is no God because
you can't prove a negative but they're
saying I don't believe there's a god so
isn't that a strange way to start this
conversation because I think there's a
feeling if you were to talk about
atheist people pick out the big ones you
know Bill Maher Richard Dawkins and
they'll say they're so egotistical they
think everything's about them and I find
that to be the reverse of what I know
about most atheists that most atheist
sort of stand in awe of everything but
let's let's get your definition first
well right I mean if you think about the
theists who think they talk to the
creator of the universe and they have a
parental relationship right there were a
trillion trillion stars in the universe
and the guy who did that knows you and
he thinks you're special and He loves
you I mean that's really the height of
hubris yeah the atheism is simply
atheism it's without the belief in a God
and a God is defined as a supernatural
intelligence okay
we're not talking about people who say
well I believe God is the universe and
God is love
those are atheists okay if you don't
think there is a supernatural
intelligence you're an atheist now that
doesn't mean you necessarily know the
entire universe it doesn't mean you've
studied everything it means you don't
have a belief in a god if you don't have
a belief in a god and you don't know the
rest of the universe you're an atheist
and if you don't have a belief in a God
and you like some of the secular
trappings of your parents religion
you're an atheist and if you don't have
a belief in a God and you absolutely
hate the word atheist tough [ __ ] you're
an atheist and and
and this is something that we really
need to get a hold of in this country
because like I told you in fighting God
I put together I crunched some numbers
and I came up with a number a defensible
number that the United States is 27%
atheist today but the polls say we're
two and a half percent
which means 90% of Americans atheists
don't call themselves 80 so basically
you come to that number because you'd
say that a certain amount of people who
say oh I'm Jewish or I'm Christian right
or whatever that they actually don't
believe but there's more of a cultural
thing that they have that associate with
it or a stigma or a social tie or one
other responsibility or another I mean
Barna 2009 said 22 percent of people who
call themselves Christians thought God
was a metaphor for the universe or love
those are atheists okay that's not
believing in God that's pretending to
believe in a god right okay
so did you guys try to have the leap of
faith because I know that I did for sure
there was a time in college when I was
smoking a lot of pot I mean I've been
I've been to Egypt I hiked Mount Sinai
that's supposedly where Moses got the
Ten Commandment mm-hmm you know I was I
was raised Catholic and I went to
Catholic school for my early elementary
school and my family was Italian
immigrants largely and so you know
Catholicism was a big part of my of my
growing up and I did allow myself to
find some solace in the in the exercise
of that but as I grew older and I began
to sort of parse down what everything
was what it really was was just I was
actually transforming all of this into a
narrative that made sense for me as a
metaphor and it was very easy to say
well I don't believe that but I also was
you know my father was a chemist
industrial chemist so he had a he was a
scientist basically my mother was a
schoolteacher there was a lot of science
in the household there was a lot of a
lot of emphasis on education I went to
the Bronx High School of Science and but
a lot of time that means nothing right
because don't you think a lot of times
there are people who can be a physicist
during the day and ask for empirical
evidence all the time or someone that
can be a teacher and want evidence and
thought and all that and then
same time they can still believe in
fairy tale I suppose that's true but it
wasn't for me yeah so it was very easy
for me to I mean for a long time I was
sort of living with it as metaphor and
not realizing that that was kind of that
was kind of crucial yeah that I didn't
actually believe but again as David says
you know you're you're my friend Glenn
Wolfe says something like you know I I'm
I'm Catholic but well really what it is
is my parents are Catholic they pick the
religion for me and now I'm it right you
know that's really what happens
you were coincidentally born into the
one true religion soon as you just spend
a little bit of time thinking about it
the whole house of cards falls apart you
know and that's actually a big part of
it is that most people will identify as
a religion which has to do with their
family background and their culture and
their place of birth and you know their
geography but really it means so little
to people that they haven't even taken
that fraction of a second to really give
it any thought because that's how
meaningless it is even when they do
identify as a particular religion I
think we all know people like that yeah
you know it's really interesting because
I've had a guy I Lear is beyond who
considers himself an atheist Muslim and
that I think his book that's coming out
in a couple weeks it's called the
Atheist Muslim and I asked him about
that well how do you decouple these
things because if you don't believe in
the tenants of it and he said that for
him it was more of a cultural thing now
and when we were talking in the green
room I was saying I'm an atheist but I'm
culturally Jewish yeah you know that
there are certain holidays that my
parents celebrated that they're crap but
you know their parents celebrated etc
etc so that's what I do or at bagels or
i watch Curb Your Enthusiasm but you you
find that to be a bit of a whitewashing
of the reality it is and you know we
have so much of a stigma against being
an atheist in this country and we have
so much of a positive pole to call
ourselves religion religious that even
atheists are very very loath to call
themselves atheist like I said 90% of us
don't call ourselves atheists a lot of
us call ourselves Christians because we
try to stay in that in that zone even
though we're we're don't believe anymore
do you think that's just because people
it's just
for to say it's safer it's more
comfortable it's also much more damaging
it's also dishonest it also makes
religion look bigger and look makes
atheism look smaller the amount of
people calling them sell the amount of
atheists calling themselves Christians
if they would call themselves atheist we
have a different country we don't have
to change any minds we just have to get
people calling themselves atheists and
what I found out when I was writing the
book is that I set out to write a
defense of Jewish atheism okay i it was
46 years old at the time and I set out
to defend Jewish atheism with data and I
failed we were born Jewish I was born
Jewish and I was a cultural Jew and I
had a Jewish ethnicity and a Jewish name
and a Jewish face and Jewish blood
running through my veins and all
non-religious right and I researched it
all and none of it's true so that that's
what I love about this discussion
because you just said well I was brought
up in a Catholic family and I kept the
metaphors and that stuff kept it for a
while and then at some point got over it
and that's basically what you found out
at 46 for the through writing this book
and that's to me why this conversation
has to be had is because it transcends
nationality in transcends color and all
of those things all the people waking up
all the time it's the one common
denominator sin I don't believe in some
stuff that you can't prove David
probably knows the statistic on this but
it's something some ridiculous
percentage of atheists who've read the
Bible Christians who've read the Bible
that atheists tend to know more about
the faiths
than the religious people do which is
why we're September 2010 some things
that don't make quite a bit of sense the
things that were they were in any other
book you go this I wait for the movie so
I think I sort of got this answer from
you but when did you actually have your
awakening were you 12 re6
when did you well I hate this is it
here's the thing is what I did get like
I actually went to church through much
of my college years but with the full
understanding that I was going to church
because it was quiet I didn't actually
go to go to services
I went there for solace and peace and to
think about things and a lot of the time
that I spent there I was writing comedy
yeah because it was nice and quiet in
the middle of church and together
laughter they don't take to that
laughing in the back writing jokes but I
will in the interest of full disclosure
I will say that I was never molested by
a any anybody in the church and this car
he still to this day I have self-esteem
issues what's wrong with me anyway so so
I kind of was in that nether region of I
don't really believe this but I get that
there's something here whatever and it
wasn't until I grew older and really I
saw how destructive religion was in the
world and I saw how divisive it was and
then you know we hit the 80s and the
late 70s and we start to see the call
Rove affect politically that the
Christian Right is suddenly becoming a
powerful entity in the political realm
and it became clear to me that no I this
there's I really have to I really have
to figure out what this is
and I have to give credit to Penn
Jillette for this because Penn and I
were very close friends and I would do a
lot of material that was essentially
atheistic but I would also incorporate a
certain amount of respect for people's
beliefs and it was Penn who actually
helped me parse that down to like well
why why do you hold respect for this why
that and and that's just purely a
comedic exercise yeah it wasn't then he
you know he wasn't trying to convince me
of anything he was really going you know
like when a joke is poorly constructed
or a joke has you know a fallacious
argument in it you know
it was that kind of a conversation and
and that sort of woke me up to yeah so
let me really look at this and go what
is worthy of respect and what isn't
worthy of respect and and where
ultimately came down on this was that
all human beings are worthy of worthy of
respect but not all ideas are worthy of
respect and not all things that people
believe worthy of respect and there's a
famous aphorism I know I've heard it
attributed to Dawkins but
don't know if that's the case which is
that I I just believe in one less God
else right you guys we don't believe in
Thor we don't believe in Zeus we don't
believe in Mithra yeah all those things
and and so the notion of not believing
in a God is pretty well entrenched in
everybody yeah it's interesting to me
you know going with the stand up side of
this for a second because so many
comedians are atheists or at least are
fighting the power structure there's so
much about religion in there that you
felt that you had to do it with a
certain amount of respect because when I
see this all the time when I'll say
something about Bill Maher I see
something on Twitter people say well
he's he's this is this ego thing that I
mentioned before it's too out there it's
too abrasive it's too whatever but he's
just not showing respect to what he
would say is probably a pretty shitty
idea the same way he would treat that
any other right shitty idea right and
you were trying to be respectful of it I
think
yeah but that also had to do with my my
immaturity both as an artist and as a
performer and and in the business - that
was you know there was a time when I
actually cared about not alienating
people so you know that mattered and I
would sort of couch it in in ways that
were where I was trying to suggest that
I respect everybody but at the same time
trying to disavow everything they
believed in yeah and you know
conversation happens yeah but you know a
lot of thing I've learned a lot of
things about big philosophical issues
through constructing jokes when you
really construct a joke with some sense
of of the I want to be truthful I want
to be honest when we read I want to be
intellectually sound in this then you
really have to face a lot of things that
are ultimately really philosophical and
I'm kind of deep look almost everything
that I believe about religion George
Carlin has said already yeah I mean I
get into a debate about this and I just
go well here's the link and that's what
I think about that well actually when I
was a kid one of the George Carlin pits
that really you know kind of helped make
me go recognize that this is a metaphor
was the baby used to do about being in
Catholic school as a little kid and go
hey father if God is all-powerful could
he make a rock so
big even he can't lift it like really so
46 you had the revelation yeah you you
couldn't consider yourself Jewish and
ease but when was your sort of atheist
awakened because you have SIA that
before I had that admitted years old six
six years old first grade first grade I
was raised in a Jewish family but I had
Christians in my Christians in my
universe and so I was one of those kids
who got both Christmas and Hanukkah
presents that was the greatest thing
ever
yeah but I was trying to figure out if
Santa Claus was real and so I devised a
plan and I lied to my mother I told my
mother that I had asked Santa Claus for
a train set and I decided if she if I
got the train set but I hadn't asked
Santa Claus for it then mom was Santa
Claus and so I'm I remember this so
clearly so one of those early memories
that you got really down path here on
the right side of the back seat of my
mother's blue Chrysler driving down the
Lynn way and Massachusetts toward my
toward my grandmother's house I'm
leaning over the front seat of the car
and I told my mother that I asked Santa
Claus for a train set and my mother said
to me Oh Dave you're too old to believe
in Santa Claus now and I said huh and I
released my arms from the front seat of
the train set and I sat back in the CETA
by the time I was seated back in the
seat I didn't believe in Santa Claus the
Easter Bunny the tooth fairy or God I
wouldn't even believe your parents
you